je vous remercie monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
je souhaitais avant tout en propos
liminaire remettre l'ensemble de cette
affaire dite affaire benalla dans le
contexte ce qui est le sien cette
affaire elle intervient au moment des
évènements dits du 1er mai de la place
de la contrescarpe dont on a dit un
certain nombre de choses mais surtout on
est en train de le constater maintenant
avec le temps qui passe
un certain nombre de contre-vérités un
certain nombre d'approximations à la
fois relié par la presse mais aussi par
un certain nombre de responsables
politiques
on m'a d'abord présenté comme le tabac
soeur des gentils manifestants
d'autres ont employé le mot opposants
politiques et d'autre les mangeurs de
crêpes comme ils se sont même présentés
en tronquant la réalité d'une situation
qui était pour le moins assez tendu et
on est en train de le découvrir depuis
plusieurs semaines assez confuse j'ai
dès le début lors de différentes
interventions médiatiques qui ont été
les miennes à la fois au jt de 20 heures
de tf1
également dans le journal du dimanche et
dans le journal le monde je suis revenu
sur cette situation du 1er mai où j'ai
expliqué que les personnes qui étaient
en face de moi n'étaient pas des gentils
manifestants mais des lanceurs de
bouteilles en verre sur des policiers ce
qui a été difficile à admettre pour un
certain nombre de journalistes pour un
certain nombre de responsables
politiques
mais ce qui s'est conclue être la
réalité dès lors que les vidéos sont
sorties dans les médias
après quelques semaines où on les a
quand même gardé sous le coude où on
voit ces deux personnes en train de
jeter des bouteilles en verre et
d'agresser littéralement les policiers
aujourd'hui ces deux personnes
je reviens qu'on a présenté comme des
gentils manifestants sont convoqués par
la justice pour répondre de faits de
violences sur dépositaire de l'autorité
publique
alors il ya également tout un contexte
autour de ça qui était de savoir est ce
que j'avais à agir pas agir ça c'est pas
à moi de vous le dire aujourd'hui
ce n'est pas le sujet de cette audition
j'ai bien compris ce sera à la justice
de déterminer si ce que j'ai fait le 1er
mai en contribuant à l'appréhension de
deux délinquants
comment je les qualifie comme ça deux
lanceurs de bouteilles sur des policiers
est ce que j'avais à le faire ou pas à
le faire j'ai pensé bien faire en vertu
d'un article s'appelle l'article 73 du
code de procédure pénale qui indique que
n'importe quel citoyen est autorisé à
appréhender l'auteur d'un crime ou d'un
délit flagrant et en l'occurrence le jet
d'une bouteille en verre sur des
policiers ça s'appelle un délit ce sont
des violences volontaires sur
dépositaire de l'autorité publique
à l'issue de ces pseudos révélations
d'un grand quotidien du soir il ya eu je
voulais déjà dit la dernière fois un
déferlement médiatique
un déchaînement politique un lâchage en
règle dont j'ai fait l'objet et je
continue d'ailleurs à faire l'objet
depuis six mois avec la construction
d'un personnage d'un individu comme l'a
pu l'appeler quelqu'un qui est venu
devant vous très récemment
alors que je constate et le mois de
septembre qui le tarissait pas d'éloges
me concernant mais vise apparemment là
sa vision a changé de manière assez
rapide
parce qu'en six mois on a réussi à
construire et à faire de moi un
personnage qu'on dise sulfureux
diabolique infréquentable enfin ce sont
tous les qualificatifs qui sont employés
à mon encontre et je pense de manière
très modeste avoir contribué à la
construction de ce personnage de par des
propos que j'ai pu tenir qui ont été
situés hors de leur contexte mais aussi
de par parfois on attitude quitté qui a
peut-être été jugée décalé et je je je
conçois que j'ai pu donner une mauvaise
image de moi mais je tenais devant vous
monsieur le président à remettre dans le
contexte cette pseudo affaire benalla où
on a bien vu le cheminement la
construction médiatico-politique qui
n'avaient qu'un seul but atteindre le
président de la république
je pense que ça a marché j'espère que ça
va se terminer assez rapidement pour mon
pays
et pour la réussite que je souhaite au
président de la république en l'espace
de six mois
les choses ont bien changé elles ont
évolué plutôt négativement en ce qui me
concerne et je dois vous le dire et le
reconnaître derrière la carapace il ya
un homme sa femme son fils qui avait un
mois et demi au moment de l'éclatement
de de cette affaire une situation
professionnelle et personnelle assez
troublée qui ont fait que j'ai commis un
certain nombre d'erreurs des erreurs que
j'ai reconnu volontiers auprès de mes
proches près de mon entourage et que je
reconnais publiquement devant vous et je
les fais également devant la justice ses
erreurs elles n'ont pu l'être de par des
rencontres de par des échanges avec
certaines personnes encore une fois
qualifié de sulfureuses et je tiens à
vous le dire je rencontre qui je veux
quand je veux et dans le cadre que je
veux en fixant des limites morales que
je garderai pour moi mais je n'accepte
pas le personnage qui a été construit
autour de moi et qu'il ne reflète pas la
réalité de ce que je suis qui je suis et
ce que j'ai fait lorsque j'étais à la
présidence de la république
je venais aussi rappelé devant vous que
j'ai été recrutés sur la base de mes
compétences qui n'ont jamais été depuis
le début de vos auditions remise en
cause par qui que ce soit par qui que ce
soit
je n'ai pas débarquer à l'elysée par
effraction j'ai participé à une campagne
électorale où j'ai exercé mes
compétences avec mes qualités et mes
défauts et ont mis à recruter sur la
seule base de mes compétences et de mon
savoir faire et je demande juste un peu
d'indulgence me concernant
de par le traitement médiatique
politique qui est le mien et je pense
que la justice qui fait son travail
sereinement a toute sa place dans notre
pays pour faire la lumière sur tout ce
qui m'a été reproché depuis le début de
cette affaire
j'ai entendu un certain nombre
d'approximations de mensonges et de
contrevérités dans les précédents
témoignages des gens que vous avez pu
auditionner
j'ai un immense respect pour les
fonctions qu'ils occupent et aujourd'hui
je ne vous parlerai pas de ce que je
pense des hommes dans la droite ligne de
ce que je vous ai dit la dernière fois
monsieur le président bas